yeah uh so as well as i was saying that
we learned today a lot uh about
the application of uh structure the
application of gaming informatics for
biomedical drug discovery
so in this entire program uh we will be
going and
learning about different aspects of
biomedical drug discovery
so we started with genomics and we
wanted to learn about the sequences and
the differences in the context of a
disease
and then we learned about the gene
expression
in the transcriptomics program and also
now we are learning going to learn about
the application of data science uh and
how we are using data science in this
entire process of biomedical drug
discovery and
uh alongside uh with the data science
and all of that
sequence based knowledge now we are
transitioning into the structural
space so it's very exciting to be able
to do this with all of you here who
would be joining us for this entire
entire course this will be a intensive
one-month course where you will have
like regular sessions
uh to discuss and where we will be going
through the topics
that you saw um that's what dr sujeeth
showed you that will be covered during
this period
and also the purpose of
doing this omix logic training programs
is to help you and guide you develop
these
learn from these techniques and develop
uh research
research ideas research projects so
one of the purpose would be to learn
from the very basics so that's why there
is two there are two phases in this
program
the first phase focuses on the
technology and the techniques
that are very much uh used in today's
biomedical drug discovery uh pipelines
so i think many of you have heard about
protein structures
and with uh the sars growth ii the
variants and how the variants change
the structure the function and all of
that so
i think we will be covering a lot of
those basic concepts of how do you
understand how do you visualize
how can you look at the structure so
that's very important
because in the end what we are trying to
find is we are trying to find different
strategies
to be able to understand and devise
using these different tools
but again uh we will have to go back to
the very basics of understanding these
3d structures
in quite detail so that we can apply
these different techniques like uh
like qsr or docking or molecular
dynamics
so in this program we will be covering
um
some of these techniques which will be
used in the context of a disease
so if you are already working and if you
are a full
program participant then we will be
working in for a project
that could be applied for these
different diseases if you already are
working on a project
so many of you are researchers here and
are working on different sort of
research topics or labs where you are
working on different projects that are
related
somehow related to by biological
research
so in that case if you're working on
structural data if you're working on
sequence data if you're working on a
protein
if you're working on some drug discovery
aspect then it's a program for you to
join because in this program you can
uh reach out to us we will be there to
guide all of the students who would be
joining uh to devise
uh the strategies and what what are the
strategies that you can take
forward to you know to
help your research go to the next level
so if you are working on some hypothesis
you have some goals
some research objectives that you have
defined in your thesis maybe that you
have defined in your
in in the next uh few days that you will
be covering
so all of those will be there uh
we'll be helping you with that so as i
was telling you the next session
would be by uh will be a free session
uh which will be an intensive session
because it's going to start
at 6 00 pm first we will have the
strategy
strategy workshop for one hour where you
will get an overview of the entire
software and what are the different
applications
so as i was telling you that omix logic
learning helps in
just not about learning it's about
application
and learning the logic so we will be
using
two propriety software's here one is the
tb info platform for
most of our analysis that we did in
genome for genomics transcriptomics
data science and also there are aspects
of data science and chemical space
uh structures uh two-dimensional or
three-dimensional structures and
molecules
that will be used for machine learning
but other than that
uh we will be using two propriety uh
softwares
uh one is the t-band for platform and
also the strategies platform
uh but the logic of the analysis would
be same for
every kind of research that you will be
doing so you can apply
those techniques and use open source
softwares in the next stage where you
are
trying to do your own research and you
not to be dependent on it
but to be learning the logic and how to
apply these techniques
and get an outcome or a result that
actually relates to the biology of the
problem so
how close you are to the uh to the
problem of mimicking this
uh in biomedical drug discovery so we
will be doing
docking simulations so we will be doing
learning about molecular dynamic
stimulation so what we are doing in this
room in those simulations
is to try to mimic the stages
where we can try to see that how the
molecule fits if it is stable or not
what would be the free energy
so all of those will be covered
in the program in the context of the
program when we will be having the
workshops
and then we will have the understanding
of how
computer aided drug discovery is useful
in this entire process
of biomedical drug discovery
so we have another session after that on
first july by dr chakra mesha and you've
already heard about
it like it would be about target
identification and validation
so how do we identify targets at the
beginning
of the experiment and if you already
have a target
then how do you validate that to be a
good target whether
if you if you find uh if you're looking
for a solution
for example if you're looking at a
disease if you're looking at
i want to work on a specific disease so
we have different examples
here um in our omega logic training
where we go we have gone through
infectious diseases so we have gone
through examples of kobit 19
malaria and tuberculosis
all of those examples uh to learn from
and then we have uh
examples in cancer research where uh
biomedical data drug discovery
and machine learning and using uh
patient information
all of that is is is much
is much used and there's a huge
application
so understanding that in the context and
how to apply
this in using uh programming languages
such as
or statistical languages such as r so
there will be another expert session by
dr
shellu from ames on
14th july that would be about gaming
informatics
using our and then
as you already have seen that
understanding the
recent advances in drug discovery
so uh as i was telling you that a
machine learning
first we learned about these techniques
then we discussed
about uh the way it is being used in
drug discovery
but in kami informatics like um i think
artificial intelligence has
inspired computational uh this
computational area drug discovery
and this widespread adaptation of
machine learning in particularly
you have heard about deep learning you
have heard about
uh the google platform uh that came up
to predict
uh uh protein structures so
understanding the way uh modern drug
discovery is working how artificial
intelligence
is uh you know enabling uh this uh
entire process of drug discovery and
it's fueling the development right
so there has been a kind of skepticism
before when we started with all of this
but this growing data and the
continuously
continuous development of these
resources have uh
really led to this entire process to be
really much more defined and now
we are believing in it and we are seeing
some results so
uh like this benefit comes from
medicinal chemistry comes from
ai comes from all of those allied fields
radiology and we are using patient data
so emr records and all of that so
understanding drug discovery
in this in this entire intensive program
would be about multi-disciplinary
aspects of drug discovery so it will not
be just about
finding a molecule and docking and just
finding the structure but to understand
in our
aspect in the aspects of uh the disease
and if there are resistance um how to
overcome that
if there is a problem of drug
repurposing
how to look at that and how to
incorporate multi-omics data as well as
gaming informatics information into a
project so these are some of the
objectives that we have start that we
have started with
and and i believe that we will be able
to complete some of these analysis
during this program and help you all
to learn from what we have gone through
in our entire career
what we have learned from uh all the
experts and
we have an uh group of experts from
a lot of experience from what they have
gone through in their own ex journey in
pharma
so i'm really excited to be a part of
this program and become and be a mentor
to many of you who would be working with
us on these different aspects
now i'd like to hand it over to sunalika
to tell you about the registration
process and
how you can how how can you come on
board and start working with us
thank you